now today marks international holocaust
remembrance day the u.n designated
january 27 a day to honor the
anniversary of when allied troops
liberated auschwitz the camp was one of
many set up by nazi germany for the
purpose of mass genocide and forced
labor jewish people were the primary
target of hitler's genocide plan with
six million people killed between 1933
and 1945. his regime also killed five
million others during that same time
period including political enemies
ethnic minorities and those attracted to
the same sex
here at home one holocaust survivor
sharing her experience how she made it
through and christian in studio joining
us with the story and the concern about
the younger generations that's right
brian and
kirsten let me tell you michelle metz is
alive today because she was kept well
hidden during that dark period in time
where unfortunately her father passed
away but it was her mother who later
remarried and that created a path of
opportunities
luck for me that i had my grandparents
luck for me that the nazis didn't find
me the meckie hit us
luck that we came to america and when
you think about the people who survived
it might not have been because of what
they did but it was luck michelle metz
is thankful today for the many blessings
she has as the world honors
international holocaust remembrance day
a dark period in history still relevant
she says and impacting us all whether
it's jews or political prisoners or
black people or native americans or
people who lived in rwanda
it's a very important thing to remember
the 78-year-old sharing these images of
her childhood and reflecting how in the
midst of darkness she was able to
survive this is the anniversary of the
liberation of auschwitz really
significant
because it's focusing on liberation
susan dublin oversees the spurling
cronberg mack holocaust remembrance
center in summerland on the walls are
the faces of some of the survivors in
southern nevada who are slowly passing
on
dublin says less than 100 are still
alive and covet now taking lives
holocaust impacted the entire world most
people don't realize that it wasn't just
germany it wasn't just eastern europe it
was throughout the world it's still
happening maybe not as methodically in
places like rwanda but it's still
happening
well the center also honoring survivors
who have passed away with a garden
memorial the stones there are original
pieces from those roads many families
had to travel back then for things like
medicine and food just to survive check
out eight newsnow dot com for more
details christian gossett is live local
now